walking on to this video playing Bureau
tech Bureau tech from Russia let's see
maybe okay maybe in a good Indian yeah
good Indian don't get that too often
he's not castling maybe intending no I
thought he might term might go for a
quick h6 and g5 sometimes people play
like that yeah this is some comparable
to Kings Indian but with somewhat
limited counter play a four maybe just
stay for keep it simple
no he was not really threatening be five
but it's often useful anyway to play a
form gaining some space possibly playing
even a five that's nice giving up the b5
square of course my square before is
also weakened but the difference is that
i actually have pieces that can go to be
five while black hair has a hard time to
use that ok I'm going with Group B 1 and
B for one idea why should I first yeah
let's first secure before here wow it's
very accommodating even weakening the b6
square 36 square what I need to be aware
of of course is that he might try to
exchange the bishop with night h7 Bishop
g5 I would always retreat to F to keep
the bishops on sometimes I could have
played Bishop c6 actually now that I
think of it this would have been
interesting doing that now
asking a black way way to put the pieces
here just putting immediate pressure on
the queenside
okay so i'm not able to take d6f because
of because of the pin ok now we just
have to work so that are actually
attacking v6 ok and so pawn takes of the
ship takes Bishop takes is probably more
flexible
yeah this position is obviously very
nice strategically but it's still not
not so clear how to how to make progress
probably probably any to do that at some
point it's hard to get ahead without it
and I can possibly can continue with
Bishop c6 and Queen B one just pressure
rising b6 further you will probably try
for counter play with safe file Bishop
g5 maybe at the bishop f2 then f5 at
least I'm hell on the clock that's
something play this preparatory move
yeah i'm not sure if i should play
something like age for am it's not it's
probably not really helping
yeah but i can't play five moves in a
row i play a key to be to the trip c6
and take v6 in fact that's not so easy
to counter
yeah when factor you really didn't have
anything to play against it I think just
look here here i guess on i can i can
even I can't even take it is not bad
yeah thats that's good enough i think i
can take here also because of a five
yeah but it's not it's not so convincing
really i have Knight b6 now i can just
take it on b6 and don't don't really see
a big big reply
I've got everything covered here all
pieces work together so there's probably
no no tactic coming night c79
I can get to before
okay I'm just to be for you I can I can
do that first and then think about it
night c4 here quite a lot hanging here
I somehow likes to continue in this
position check black for fits on time
yeah it became very one-sided at some
point I mean the whole the whole
structure here with a 5 and b6 is of
course very favorable for white because
i have this the squares to invade and
it's it's very tricky to defend simply
you don't get this batch Bishop
exchanged on his heaven and town and Sam
and don't really either really dislike
black here that's yeah you know here
here the computer already wants to
sacrifice the exchange and gives widen
almost winning advantage quite quite
amazing I mean it's clear that white has
excellent compensation but um the
witness win is a bit much yeah it is
very good it is very good to have the
deep pawn to bishops tastic position but
still came and eerie didn't want to
sacrifice because I mean this is just an
excellent position without any material
down and here i just played this it's
it's the exact computer line it looks
very computer ish my plate but it's it's
it's just logical putting everything
against this pawn and here Bishop g7 is
even stronger down with a five coming
but okay what I did is this is perfectly
only one points to win in a game of
chess yeah black um I think black
structures already a bit bit if he here
but going with with I mean like like
here going with a five and b6 is really
helping wide alright thanks for watching